in my humble opinion the single most
important biochemical reaction
especially to us is cellular cellular
respiration and the reason why I feel so
strongly about that is because this is
how we derive energy from what we eat or
from our fuel or if we want to be
specific from glucose at the end of the
day most of what we or at least
carbohydrates end up is glucose in the
future videos I'll talk about how we
derive energy from fats or proteins but
cellular respiration let's go from
glucose from glucose to energy and some
other byproducts and to be a little bit
more specific about it let me write the
chemical reaction right here so that so
the chemical formula for glucose you're
going to have six carbons 12 hydrogen's
and six oxygens so that's your glucose
right there so if you had one mole of
glucose right that that's your glucose
right there and then to that one mole of
glucose if you had six moles of
molecular oxygen running around the cell
then and this is kind of a gross
simplification for cellular respiration
I think you're going to appreciate over
the course of the next few videos that
one can get as involved into this into
this mechanism as possible I think it's
nice to get the big picture but if you
give me some glucose if you have one
mole of glucose and six moles of oxygen
through the process of cellular
respiration and so I'm just writing it
it's kind of a big black box right now
let me pick a nice color so this is
cellular cellular respiration which
we'll see is quite involved but I guess
anything can be if you want to be
particular about it through cellular
respiration we're going to produce six
moles of carbon dioxide six moles of
water and and this is the key this is
the the super important part and we're
going to produce energy we're going to
produce energy and this is the energy
that we're going to that that can be
used to
to a useful work to put to heat our
bodies to to provide electrical impulses
in our brains whatever whatever energy
of especially human body needs but it's
not just humans it's provided by this
cellular respiration mechanism and when
you same energy you might say hey Sal
you know in the last video didn't you
just well if you if that was the last
video you watched you probably saw that
I said that ATP ATP is the energy
currency is the energy currency for
biological systems and so you might say
hey well looks like glucose is the
energy currency for biological systems
and to some degree both both answers
would be correct but to just see how it
kind of fits together is that the
process of cellular respiration it does
produce energy directly but that energy
is used to produce ATP so if I were to
break down this energy portion of
cellular respiration right there some of
it would just be heat you know it just
warms up the cell and then some of it is
used and this is what the textbooks will
tell you the textbooks will say it
produces 38 ATP's that can be more
readily used by cells to contract
muscles or to generate nerve impulses or
do whatever else or grow or divide or
whatever else the cell might need so
really cellular respiration to say it
produces energy little disingenuous it's
really the process of taking glucose and
producing ATP's with maybe heat as a
by-product but it's probably nice to
have that heat around we need we need we
need to be reasonably warm in order for
our cells to operate correctly so the
whole point is really to go from glucose
from one mole of glucose and the
textbooks will tell you to 38 ATP's and
the reality is this is in kind of the
ideal circumstances that you'll produce
38 ATP's I was reading up about it a
little bit before doing this video and
the reality is depending on the
efficiency of the cell and performing
cellular respiration it'll probably be
more on the order of 29 to 30 ATP's but
there's huge variation here and people
are are really still studying this idea
but this is all cellular
operation is in the next few videos
we're going to break it down into its
kind of constituent parts and I'm going
to introduce them to you right now just
so you kind of realize that these are
parts of cellular respiration the first
stage is called glycolysis glycolysis
which literally means breaking up
glucose and just so you know this is
part you know this the gly for glucose
and or the glyco for glucose really the
glyco for glucose and then lysis means
to break up when you saw hydrolysis it
means using water to break up a molecule
glycolysis this means we're going to be
breaking up glucose and in case you care
about things like word origins glucose
comes from the glue the glue cart of
glucose comes for Greek for sweet and
glucose is indeed sweet and then all
sugars we put this O's ending so that
just means sugar so you might think it's
kind of a redundant statement to say
sweet sugar but there are some sugars
that aren't sweet for example lactose
and you know milk it might be a little
bit but you know when you actually when
you actually digest lactose and you can
turn it into an actual sweet sugar but
it doesn't taste sweet like glucose or
fructose with actual or sucrose would
taste but anyway that's a that's an
aside but the first step of cellular
respiration is glycolysis breaking up of
glucose and what it does is it breaks up
the glucose from a six carbon from a six
carbon molecule so it literally takes it
from a six carbon molecule we draw it
like this a six carbon molecule that
looks like this and it's actually a
cycle let me show you what glucose
actually looks like this is glucose
right here and notice you have one two
three four five six carbons I got this
off of Wikipedia just look up glucose
and you can see this diagram if you want
to kind of see the details where you
know you can see I have six carbons six
oxygens that's one two three four five
six and then all of these little small
blue things are my hydrogen so that's
what glucose actually looks like but the
process of glycolysis you're essentially
just taking that I'm writing it out as a
kind of a string but
can imagine it as a chain and it has
oxygens and hydrogen's added to it to
each of these carbons but that has a
carbon backbone and it breaks that
carbon back groans into into two that's
what glycolysis does right there so you
kind of lysed the glucose and each of
these things and I haven't drawn all the
other stuff that's added on to that you
know these things are all bonded with
other things with oxygens and hydrogen's
whatever but each of these three carbon
backbone molecules are called pyruvate
we'll go into a lot more detail on that
but by glycolysis it generates it by
itself generates well it needs two ATP's
so it needs two ATP's and it generates
generates four ATP's so net net on a net
basis it generates two let me write this
in a different color
it generates two net two net ATP so
that's the first age and this this can
occur completely in the absence of
oxygen I'll do a whole video on
glycolysis in the future then these
byproducts they get re-engineered a
little bit and then they enter into
what's called the Krebs cycle they enter
what's called the Krebs krebs cycle
which generates another two ATP and then
and this is the this is kind of the
interesting point there's another
process that you can kind of say happens
after the Krebs cycle but we're in a
cell and everything is bumping into
everything all of the time but it's
normally kind of viewed to be after
glycolysis and the Krebs cycle and this
requires let me make this requires
oxygen requires oxygen so let me be
clear glycolysis this first step no
oxygen required or doesn't need oxygen
oxygen it can occur with oxygen or
without it oxygen not needed oxygen not
needed or you could say this is called
an anaerobic process this is you know
this is the anaerobic part
the respiration let me write that down
to anaerobic maybe I'll write it down
here glycolysis glycolysis since it
doesn't need oxygen we can say it's
anaerobic you might be familiar with the
idea of aerobic exercise the whole idea
of aerobic exercise is to make you
breathe hard because you need a lot of
oxygen to do aerobic exercises so
anaerobic means you don't need oxygen
aerobic means it needs oxygen anaerobic
means the opposite you don't need oxygen
so glycolysis anaerobic and it produces
two ATP's net and then you go to the
Krebs cycle then you go to the Krebs
cycle there's a little bit of setup
involved here and we'll do the detail on
that in the future but then you move
over to the Krebs cycle which is aerobic
it is aerobic it requires oxygen to be
around and then this produces two ATP's
and then this is the part that frankly
when I first learned it confused me a
lot but I'll just write it in order the
way it's traditionally rote then you
have something called reusing the same
colors too much you have something
called the electron transport chain
electron transport chain and this part
gets credit for producing the bulk of
the ATP's 34 ATP's and this is also
aerobic it requires oxygen so you can
see with if you had no oxygen if you
weren't if the cells weren't getting
enough oxygen you can produce a little
bit of energy but if you don't but it's
nowhere near as much as you can produce
once you have the oxygen and actually
when you're when you start running out
of oxygen you know this can't proceed
forward so what happens is some of these
byproducts of glycolysis instead of
going into the Krebs cycle and the
electron transport chain where they need
oxygen instead they go through a side
process called fermentation fermentation
for some organisms this process of
fermentation takes your byproducts of
glycolysis and literally produces
alcohol that's where alcohol
comes from that's called alcohol
fermentation and we as human beings I
guess fortunately or unfortunately our
muscles do not directly produce alcohol
they produce lactic acid so we probably
do lactic acid fermentation
write that down lactic acid that's
humans and probably other mammals humans
but other things like yeast will do so
yeast will do alcohol form fermentation
alcohol alcohol fermentation so this is
when you don't have oxygen it's actually
this lactic acid that if I were to you
know sprint really hard and not be able
to get enough oxygen that my muscles
start to ache because this lactic acid
starts to build up but that's just a
side thing if we have oxygen we can move
to the krebs cycle get our two ATP's and
then go on to the electron transport
chain and produce 34 ATP's which is
really the bulk of what happens in
respiration now I kind of said this as
an aside that you know to some degree
this isn't fair because while these guys
are operating they're also producing
these other molecules or let me they're
not producing them entirely but what
they're doing is they're taking I know
it gets complicated here but I think
over the course of the next few videos
we'll get an intuition for it in these
two parts of the reaction glycolysis and
the Krebs cycle we're constantly taking
nad alright as nad plus and we're adding
hydrogen's to it to form NADH and this
actually happens for ten for one
molecule of glucose this happens to ten
nad s or ten nad plus is to become NADH
s and those are actually what drive the
electron transport chain and I'll talk a
lot more about it and kind of how that
happens and why is energy being derived
and and how is this an oxidative
reaction and all of that and you know
what's getting oxidized in what's being
reduced but I just wanted to give due
credit these guys aren't just producing
two atps in each each of these stages
they're also producing actually combined
ten nadh --is which are then use which
each which each produce three ATP's in
an ideal situation the electron
transport chain and they're also doing
it this other molecule FA D which is
very similar but they're producing FA F
eh now I know all of this is very
complicated I'll make videos on this in
the future but the important thing to
remember is cellular respiration all it
is is taking glucose and kind of
repackaging the energy and glucose and
repackaging it in the form of your
textbooks will tell you 38 ATP's and if
taking the exam that's a good number to
write it tends to in reality be a
smaller number it's also going to
produce heat actually most of it is
going to be heat but 38 ATP's and it
does it through three stages the first
stage is glycolysis where you're just
literally splitting splitting the
glucose into two you're generating some
ATP's but the more important thing is
you're generating some NADH s that are
going to be used later in the electron
transport chain then those byproducts
are split even more in the Krebs cycle
directly producing two atps but that
produces a lot more NADH s and then all
of those NADH s are used in the electron
transport chain to produce the bulk of
your of your energy currency or your 34
ATP's